I think there's so many so many in all
political parties uh who've just turned
their backs on women as well as huge
sways of the population you know most
people know that women don't have
penises and and it's about time that
parties said it and the the conservative
party are a little bit too late with
their their sort of strengths on this
topic and they're still really not far
enough for me you know there's still
this stuff has has got ravaged through
schools you know the I I visited a
school recently it's this stuff is
everywhere so there is a there is a
calling for a party that represents
women and that would be mine